[Music]
so we finally have the official Avengers
4 trailer officially Avengers endgame
and although this is only a teaser
trailer it was pretty intense and of
course we finally got the official title
they waited all the way until the first
teaser trailer came out but we finally
got it Avengers end game so just clarify
this is my personal breakdown I have
actually done an analysis with a special
guest that I'll be doing in a separate
video as well but this is my personal
breakdown so let's just jump right into
it so we start with a very eerie scene
with iron man's helmet just destroyed
this of course is the result from his
fight with Thanos on Titan and he used a
good amount of his nanobots up when he
fought him as we saw an infinity war it
starts with him turning it on tapping on
it to see if it's working saying is this
thing on because he's recording a
message for pepper if you noticed that a
blue light from the helmet sort of scans
over him so maybe this is a video
recording but no doubt that he is
recording a message to pepper here and
it's really sad because he's stranded in
space right now he's on star-lord ship
which actually answers a question that
many many people had about an infinity
war which was our Tony and nebula
actually stuck on Titan or was star-lord
ship still there a lot of people thought
that since Thanos threw the moon at it
or part of the moon at Titan that maybe
the ship was destroyed it clearly was
not because he's on it now nebula is
there too we find that out in a later
scene but as of right now she sort of
just giving him his space because he's
about to die he says that food and water
ran out four days ago and his oxygen
supply will run out tomorrow so for Tony
this is it this is the end of the line
for him and it shows him staring off
into space just thinking about
everything that's happened and of course
at the end the last thing he thinks
about is pepper his fiancee the love of
his life so this is Tony giving up he
just got crushed by Thanos Thanos
performed the snap and then Tony got
stranded in space he's just run out of
food and he's just run out of water and
he's gonna run out of oxygen and he's
gonna die so he records his final
message to pepper his fiancee and then
he turns it off and accepts his fate so
that's pretty much the first minute of
the trailer and it's supposed to be like
that it's supposed to be heavy it's
supposed to be in
because the last thing that happened was
the snap
The Avengers lost Thanos won so Avengers
infinity war ends with an Avengers end
game starts with the defeat of the
Avengers then of course we have the
Marvel Studios logo and of course it
turns to dust and then we see the Thanos
scarecrow and we actually saw this at
the end of Avengers infinity war and
this is actually sort of a tribute to
the comics because in the Infinity
Gauntlet saga when Thanos is defeated he
goes and becomes farmer Thanos and he
puts his armor on a scarecrow in an
attempt to scare anybody who may come
and then we kind of see fan oohs it
doesn't completely show us Thanos what
it really focuses on here is the
Infinity Gauntlet because if you take a
look at the Infinity Gauntlet you can
notice that it is still damaged from the
snap
we know the gauntlet is permanently
damaged the Russo brothers have said
this themselves they said that there was
a cost to using the Infinity Gauntlet
and performing the snap and it
permanently damaged Thanos and the
Infinity Gauntlet the Russo brothers
have also confirmed that this is in fact
a different planet it's tightened to a
new home for Thanos so Thanos is on a
different planet and he and the Infinity
Gauntlet are permanently damaged right
now then we cut to the Avengers facility
where Black Widow is saying that Thanos
did exactly what he said he was going to
do he wiped out 50 percent of all living
creatures and you can see Natasha sort
of choked up when she says that and you
can see Steve crying because not only
did they just lose people that they
loved but they lost as the Avengers they
weren't able to prevent the snap they
weren't able to prevent half of the
universe being wiped away from existence
and then we have this scene right here
where Bruce Banner is looking at a
holograph screen and it shows missing
persons and you see Scott Lang and you
also see Sheree now you can notice that
those red letters to the bottom right of
each picture says missing this is kind
of interesting because they don't really
know where these heroes are they don't
know where Scott Lang is because he
wasn't in the events of infinity war but
it's really interesting that Sheree is
on there because they were in Wakanda
and she was in Wakanda too and the Russo
brothers at one point in time said that
she did in fact survive the snap
a good majority of the Avengers were in
Wakanda Cherie was helping them they all
met Cherie so did she fall victim to the
snap or did she perhaps run away
somewhere for whatever reason because
the Russo brothers did say that she
survived but that could always change
there was a lot of filming that happened
in between when they said she's survived
and the teaser trailer but then you can
see that her picture actually changes to
Peter Parker it's very curious that they
have Peter Parker up there because this
is clearly a missing Avengers profile
list here but I wasn't exactly sure if
any of the remaining Avengers actually
knew spider-man was Peter Parker clearly
they must have known or somehow found
out because he's there but they
obviously do not know where he is
because he's on their missing persons
list then we see a clip of an empty
Avengers headquarters then we see Thor
because he's back on earth now because
he went and got Stormbreaker came back
fought the Battle of Wakanda almost
killed Thanos and now he's with the rest
of the Avengers so now we hear Steve
Rogers voice in the background saying we
lost all of us and then we have this
scene right here with nebula she's on
the ship with Tony and as you can see
here she kind of enters the room that
Tony's in very slowly very cautiously
and she puts her hand on his shoulder
right as Steve Rogers says we lost
friends now Steve's not on the ship
that's just narration but look at the
way that she moves her hand off of his
shoulder she removes it like he's dead
like he's gone and she enters the room
sort of like she doesn't know if he's
going to be dead or alive so I think
there is a possibility that Tony may
actually die in the beginning of this
movie because nebula is pretty much half
machine Dana's ripped a good majority of
her body parts out and replaced them
with mechanical body parts so she can
most likely survive without oxygen and
without food so this isn't the end for
her it's the end for Tony and then we
get our first look at Ronan and it's
interesting that they show him as Steve
Rogers says we lost family and we lost a
part of ourselves because in the comics
Hawkeye becomes Ronan when Steve Rogers
dies and this tragedy Clint gives up his
Hawkeye persona and becomes Ronan so my
guess is and I've been saying this for a
while in a few different videos is that
Clint's family fell victim to this
they got wiped away and during the
tragedy of losing his family not only
did he lose his family but he did lose a
part of himself and then he picks up the
persona of Ronin so from what we know he
is in Japan trying to infiltrate the
Yakuza and as you can see Natasha is
there she clearly went out looking for
him and it seems like she found him
right as he killed a bunch of people so
as you can see Clint or Ronan is not
playing around in this movie we then cut
to the scene with Black Widow and
Captain America and Steve is staring at
a picture of Peggy and noticed that he's
wearing his uniform from Captain America
the Winter Soldier Natasha says this is
gonna work Steven he says I know it is
because I don't know what I'm gonna do
if it doesn't this could be pointing to
time travel the old picture the old
uniform and the fact that ant-man shows
up in another scene in the trailer
because remember that the sequences that
they show you in the trailer are not
necessarily the sequences that are in
the movie in fact more often than not
they're not they're out of order so
ant-man could have told them about a
time vortex that he discovered inside of
the quantum realm and they could have
decided that that's how they're going to
undo the snap time-travel and look at
how they revealed the title notice how a
bunch of different rocks are being put
back together to make the a and make the
title end game it looks like the logo
and the title were broken were smashed
into pieces and time is being reversed
to have them come back together it
clearly looks like time is rewinding and
it's coming back together and if you
notice there is a circle a ring going
around it and as it comes back together
it's spinning this could perhaps be a
portal entrance to the quantum realm
because again a time vortex was
mentioned inside of the quantum realm in
ant-man
and the wasp and the last time we saw
Scott Lang he was stuck inside of the
quantum realm that's me can you buzz me
in so whether or not he gets out through
a time vortex he definitely knows about
the time vortex and when he goes and
finds Steve and Natasha they'll of
course tell him what happened and
explained that oh snap to him in which
he will probably mention the time vortex
as that's probably going to be their
only option to defeat Thanos is to go
back in time so I really think that
that's what we're seeing here the logo
was shattered and time is being reversed
and that's what makes it come back
together and then in the last scene we
have ant-man arriving to the Avengers
facility
he seems really
really panicked because he most likely
just got out of the quantum realm and
once he got out he probably couldn't
find anybody hope Janet and dr. Pym are
all gone
Cassie might be gone Lewis might be gone
everybody that he knows probably is gone
of course half of the population of
Earth is gone so he'll notice once he
gets out in the city and once he notices
the first place he'll head is of course
the Avengers facility and clearly Steve
and Natasha thought he fell victim to
the snap they thought he was dusted away
because they are super shocked to see
him Steve even asked if it's an old
message but it's not it's current and
he's at the front gate of the Avengers
facility what's interesting is that
Scott mentions three years ago he
mentions the airport fight in Germany
well this debunks the rumor that
Avengers endgame takes place five years
after the snap and especially because we
see Tony stranded in space it's not five
years later he's not on earth or
anywhere else him and nebula leave Titan
to try and find the closest planet with
civilization on it which clearly they
don't find because Tony's about to die
but perhaps Pepper Potts comes and
rescues him we know that she's going to
be donning the rescue armor in Avengers
in game so perhaps when Tony turns on
his helmet she is somehow able to track
his location so maybe she puts on the
rescue armor because she goes and
rescues Tony
so Avengers end game does not take place
five years into the future it takes
place right after the snap so that is it
for my breakdown of Avengers end game I
hope you all enjoyed it I hope you all
enjoyed the teaser trailer I thought it
was awesome and be sure to look out for
my next video coming out tonight I'll be
doing an in-depth analysis of the
trailer with a very special guest I'm
doing a new giveaway I'm giving away a
life-size Infinity Gauntlet all you have
to do to enter for your chance to win is
be subscribed to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
super awesome day finally got the
trailer and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]